this is the Jocko underground podcast
sitting here with Echo Charles going
back to the biases oh taking a look at
the biases let's let's face it if you're
not paying attention to biases that are
in your head you're going to make some
bad
decisions they're going to be things
that you don't recognize that's what's
scary about them it's
just like anything else if you don't
know it's happening and it's happening
that's the scariest thing that's like uh
in fighting you know they say the punch
that you don't see is the one that's
going to catch you yeah right if you see
a comment you're gonna be all right
right
biases if you don't see them yeah
they're going to catch you and you're
going to do dumb stuff one of them
that hit me the other day was the loss
aversion bias
and I uh there's a website called the
decisionlab.com I think it I was reading
through a bunch of different websites
but this one kind of had a cool
definition here
this is something you got to pay
attention to if you're not paying
attention to this you're making so many
bad decisions loss aversion is a
cognitive bias that describes why for
individuals the pain of losing is
psychologically twice as powerful as the
pleasure of gaining
so if you think about right there the
way how how much that inhibits your
thought process it goes on to say the
loss from the loss felt from money or
any other valuable object can feel worse
than gaining that same thing loss
aversion refers to an individual's
tendency to prefer avoiding losses to
acquiring equivalent gains simply put
it's better not to lose 20 than it is to
find twenty dollars
and they had like a little cartoon you
find ten dollars on the ground you're
like oh cool you're excited but you're
limited excitement yeah
but if you're looking for the ten
dollars and you lost it you're bummed
true so a couple other points about this
loss aversion is
it gets stronger the bigger the stakes
are obvious I guess that's an obvious
correlation the more you stand to lose
the more your loss aversion is and you
start to weigh that against the gains
and you think this is why this was a
cool an interesting thing I didn't think
of
this is why free trial periods work
that's why they work because right you
get the hey join you know this website
join this streaming service
for free for three month trial period
and you're kind of you know so you get
it look one part is you might just
forget about it right yeah and all of a
sudden you're getting like billed for
something you don't really remember it
but also
you don't want to have to give it up
yeah you feel like you got to give it up
you feel like you're losing it and you'd
rather just hang on to it yeah
and that's that's a problem so
the scary thing from a decision is it
causes US problems because we don't want
to take risks because we don't want to
lose anything
and a lot of decisions that we have to
make there is the risk of losing
and so what do we do we don't execute
um we don't like to lose
I've seen this ruin people right or no
that's a strong statement I can't say
that that's a little strong
I've seen people fall victim to this and
it has a big negative impact on their
life
uh and you know from a tactical
perspective
you know you hear me talk about default
aggressive and you hear me talk about
the fact that default aggressive the
reason we the reason you have to be
default aggressive is because when
something's going wrong on the
battlefield
and you're gonna go do something about
it there's risks that you make a bad
decision and you look like an idiot or
something bad happens like you you know
you make a call you make a decision
there's risk that someone you know you
say go assault that building there's a
risk someone gets killed assaulting that
building
so what we have a tendency to do is we
don't want to take that risk so we're
not going to do anything and when you're
not doing anything now the enemy's
maneuvering on you they're flanking you
and you're getting you're getting worse
in a worse situation
so that's the that's the Tactical
example but it makes it real obvious
that if you have an opportunity in
business and you're like well it's going
to cost me the you know this much money
to you know when there's a chance I lose
that money and you're like ah you know
what I'm just not going to do it I'm not
saying be stupid
I think people get worried about how you
know it's the ego it's the ego loss that
that people avoid as well
like oh I don't want to get you know I
don't want to lose here I don't want to
look bad I want to look stupid so
they're like I'm just not going to do it
so that's a problem
um a couple things about how to avoid it
and this is going back to that decision
lab had a couple examples in there uh
was frame the decision in a way that
highlights the upside she's like man I
could lose 1500 bucks yeah but listen
Echo you could lose 1500 bucks but if
this thing's successful you could
quadruple that money you could have a
long-term stake in this bit whatever
yeah you start looking at it from that
direction
which is you know what's funny is when
someone's trying to like hype you up or
sell you something they're always
focused so hardcore that I look out for
those bastards as well right because
like no no sorry man you hear those if
you've been pitched like things before
like businesses and stuff sure and
they're like look this is gonna be this
is a 10x opportunity unicorn the whole
nine yards and you're like bro
no not a unicorn
cures another one that I thought was
this is something that I think I do
this is so the first the first way to
avoid it is to like frame and focus on
the upsides the other one is to look at
the worst case of what could actually
happen this is something I do
you know hey look worst case I'm gonna
lose 1500 bucks is that that big of a
deal no at this juncture in my life
losing 1500 bucks I'm gonna be able to
weather the storm financially yeah you
know it's not gonna impact me in a big
way
I I you know you look at a situation you
go hey what's the worst thing that could
happen
what's the word you know I when I try to
chill people out that are going to speak
you know they're going to speak in
public and maybe they're nervous about
it what's the worst thing that could
happen the worst thing that happens you
know what I hey I shouldn't have said
what I just said I meant to say it like
this no big deal no one cares no one
notices
you know just just it's not going to be
that bad
what's the worst possible thing that
could happen
and you look at uh
an opportunity
and you say well what is actually the
worst thing that could happen it's
probably
once you analyze it you think well
that's actually not that big of a deal
okay I can push forward
um and then like I said my my thing is
to make things you know to to go into
that default aggressive mode where I'm
gonna make things happen and listen it's
seven out of ten this doesn't mean you
always run to the sound of the guns with
you know charging into the combat
without checking out what's going on
it's not that doesn't mean you throw
money at every investment that comes
along it doesn't mean that you attack
every problem without analyzing it but
your default mode
should be to to take action
and once it doesn't mean you have to
take Massive Action but take some action
maybe a little iterative decision a
little iterative movement and it's going
to help you so
check that out
that's
a good way to counter this natural bias
that we all have which is loss aversion
so when you're looking at a situation
when you've got to make a decision what
tell yourself hey I like every other
human being likely has some loss of
version I'm trying to watch out for and
I need to counter that know your biases
so you can overcome them
yeah you that's interesting you brought
up the the sales tactic of the free
trial
because a lot of times sometimes that
doesn't work right because then you
mentioned like oh yeah if it's if you
forget about the thing or if that thing
isn't that big of a deal but if it like
if it recalibrates your standard of life
in whatever way and then now you have to
basically lose a little bit of that
standard then it feels like it works a
lot
um but it can
that's kind of how the sales people kind
of get you yeah where they'll be like
they'll
they work on or they try to anyway in my
experience that they try to recalibrate
your standard of life so they feed like
a lot of times like they'll feed you uh
like ideas of a dream a new life right
like a different life and improved life
and they keep that in your mind right
like a um I remember I used to work with
this guy who who used to sell cars oh
yeah they get him in that upgraded model
yeah yes there's all these little
tactics that they kind of they teach
them how to do or whatever but one of
the small little things that I was like
oh I see that a lot of it was like oh
okay that makes sense like I wasn't
surprised but one of them was um he'd
have this kind of Spiel and he's and it
was something along the lines of well
let me you know let me go ahead and run
these numbers and see if we can't get
you driving home in your brand new car
today so he'll say get you driving home
in your brand new car today right so it
puts this image of your head of driving
home in your brand new car right which
is like that it's like living life right
kind of a thing with your new standard
of life kind of a thing
and I remember thinking oh man that was
kind of powerful the way he said that
right there because the idea of driving
home in your new car is always exciting
right or having it yeah so and I
remember thinking that and let's say it
doesn't work out that that little model
that you recalibrated in your head gets
you you suffer this right here so you're
like oh my gosh so now they can sort of
jack up the price here and there because
you're trying to like they got you on
the hook with this exact thing
it's like with uh whatever like the show
models of like uh condos right well yeah
we can definitely uh oh you want to buy
a one bedroom condo yeah it's great hey
you know what we don't have a floor
model ready right now to show you let me
show you the two bedroom you know and
then you're walking in there you're all
fired up you're like dang this could be
like an office and I got all this extra
room and then and then they might even
show you the three bedroom then they
take you in the one bedroom and it seems
tiny and you in your mind you already
have that three that two bedroom at a
minimum yeah so you're ready to step up
there's another thing called anchoring
too which is
I guess it kind is like feeds into this
a little bit too it's like anchoring is
like when they when they show you the
really good one first yeah and then so
that's like the standard that's the
positive anchoring yeah it's a negative
anchoring too which is when when I'm
offering you you know you want to sell
me your car for 10 grand and I and you
you say well how much you want to pay
for it and I go I don't know I'll give
you like
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground